the jurogan experience can we talk for a
second about francis and ghana doing jiu
jitsu and then wild whole
first off i was scared of him before
because if he hits you you're going to
die bro his leg was destroyed going into
that fight he had a totally torn mcl his
achievement seriously yeah always
surgery because he had
knee sleeves
somebody was asking me about surgery
does the does the opponent have to agree
to let him wear those no no um we were
in california
and in california it's legal to have
knee sleeves on there are some
jurisdictions where they'll let you tape
your ankles
some commissions i'm going to cough
again
some commissions will let you tape your
ankles well
it's like there are there's all sorts of
different rules when it comes to mma
unfortunately
there's like the unified rules of mma
there's the there's the changed unified
rules that like they've changed some of
the parameters like what constitutes a
downed opponent and then some places
will let you tape your ankles someplace
as well it's like there's a lot going on
he did the smart move though
both knees yeah so you don't you don't
yeah you don't you don't put tape on
like just two fingers you're like i'm
fine no would you remember sakuraba
knees were so [ __ ] that he would tape
all the way up halfway up his thigh
where his knees were like mummified
his how much flexion and extension did
he have very little very little yeah
when you would see sakuraba when he
fought like especially later in his
career his knees were the craziest thing
see if you can find
a video of sakura but with his oh my
look how taped up his knees are i mean
it's like halfway up his thigh and
halfway down to his ankle
dude when francis picked up that guy mid
kick and they both left the ground oh
yeah he came down oh yeah all i could
think of in my head while watching that
was imagining like in a cartoon the
ghost of my body just floating up
i mean what does he weigh
well he weighed in
at 257
which but how tall is he he's six five
i believe that's deadly tall yeah yeah
dudley tall uh that's the
slamming down to the ground
then that's again where my ghost what
not look at the faces in the background
look at that dude with his mouth open
look at that girl here the girl on the
left right underneath his knee oh yeah
right there every single face
everybody's like holy [ __ ]
yeah
well
that was his best uh option to win that
fight giving the fact that he was
injured
i had no idea that he was injured
obviously significant he wasn't talking
about that before though was he um
well we knew about it okay we had heard
about it there was a rumor going around
we had heard about it um i had not
talked to his coaches so i didn't know
exactly the extent of the injury and i
found out afterwards and i actually
connected uh some one of his coaches
with uh ways to well which is a company
that i use here in austin for stem cells
but he
had uh significant tears in his knee
like to the point where they were
they're really considering not fighting
oh damn yeah but i just still fought you
still won it was beautiful a man that
size so he weighed into 257 what do you
think he stepped in the ring at well dc
thinks he's about 270 because he was so
he looked so much bigger than cyril gone
because cyril gone was 247 which means
cyril gone didn't have to lose any
weight that he just he waited his walk
around right but francis often times is
over the 265 pound limit so when he
goes to weigh in like he'll just not eat
very much like the day before under it
dip under it and then weigh himself in
and then afterwards he'll rehydrate and
carb up
so the day of the fight he looked
massive i mean he was he was huge he
looked huge but he moved
beautifully well especially for a guy
with a [ __ ] knee yeah i had no idea i
mean you got you also have to take into
consideration
what what kind of an impact that have on
his training in terms of his cardio like
his cardio output like what was he able
to do
and you know how was that going to
affect the way he fought and the pace
that he was able to fight at
all i'll say is france francis anganu is
one of the best arguments for carrying a
gun on the face of the planet because if
you run into that dude in an alleyway
you're going to die yeah you're not
you're not going to hurt him
yeah i mean stipe landed some big shots
on him and didn't even ding them that's
why tools exist sometimes you need to
you need to have tools yeah what's
interesting is that guy evolving his
game and then incorporating wrestling
and incorporating jiu jitsu and uh i'm
i'm really curious to see what he
decides to do in the future if he
decides to box or if he decides to stay
with the ufc because
part of me wants to see
him um
i want to see him box
i mean i don't want to see him box
because i don't love seeing him fight
mma i love seeing him fight mma but i
want to see him box because
i want to see him get a giant chunk of
money like like uh conor mcgregor's
style floyd mayweather chunk of money
because when conor fought floyd
mayweather made a hundred million
dollars
that's i don't believe that's bad for an
evening's work i think that's nice
i would love to see that like if if
you know if he fought tyson fury how
much money would they be able to get
i know nothing about that world do you
think they'd be able to demand that much
i don't know is it off the pay-per-view
or what they could sell yeah it's off
the pay-per-view it's off what they
could i mean obviously you'd have to
it would have to be very marketable and
tyson fury's very marketable and francis
and ghana was very marketable especially
him as a ufc heavyweight champion going
up to fight in boxing
and it would be weird to see tyson fury
like a legit five inches taller than
francis ingano because that's a good
what
oh yeah tyson fury is six nine
i think uh francis is six four or six
five i'm not sure so what how tall is
francis is he six four six five but uh
the big fight in mma is jon jones
so if uh does he fight at that same
weight jon jones is fighting heavyweight
now is there a weight class above the
265 there is but the ufc has never
implemented it it's just not super
heavyweight there's just not boys out
there big enough to i mean i guess
there's probably a few but there's not
enough where they felt the need to have
a over 265 pound weight class it is kind
of weird though that there's a weight
limit on heavy weight
because everything like heavyweight
would just like be the biggest person
you had that's what i figured i figured
at that level it was like kind of come
as you are
i mean it could be one day there you
know one day there could be a guy who is
so compelling like maybe there's some
like gigantic recovering wrestler like
corellon like corellon in his prime i
think was like 290 pounds something
bigger than that yeah if you did have a
guide that big that was marketable i
could see the ufc implementing a super
heavyweight division but
it's available i mean it's something
that the commissions have sanctioned